welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and this year's
stranger things day AKA November 6th the
day will buyers first vanished in 1983
brought with it a couple of hints for
the final season of the series not only
did Netflix bless us with a brand new
poster for me to break down they also
surprised fans by adding stranger things
character avatars to their personalized
settings menu and by dropping the first
episode title of season five but there
are a couple of very important details
that stood out to me in these seemingly
innocent promotional materials so today
I'm going to break down some of the
visual details dropped on Twitter and
explain why I think stranger things is
already teasing Eddie Munson's
Resurrection in return this video is
brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform for building your
brand more on them later to start let's
check out the official stranger things
Day poster it's chock full of references
to the first four seasons most of them
are pretty recognizable so I'll just
list them quickly we've got the trash
can Shield signs for the arcade and
Hawkins High School a rainbow that
represents Brenner's Rainbow Room
experiments the Hellfire club's t-shirt
Steve's nail ribbon baseball bat both
Justin's hats and Lucas's basketball and
slingshot we've also got a walkie-talkie
Farrah Fawcett hairspray Max's
skateboard one of the boys bicycles
Eddie's guitar Max's Walkman and
cassettes deckness clock and the sign
for Benny's Burgers next there's the
Hawkins Power and Light band aka the
shell Corporation posing as an electric
company to cover up the experiments
subjected to 11 and her siblings below
the van's wheel there's a floating Coke
can a stained glass rose doorway from
the creel house and a D20 here we see
one of the Flyers that Tina handed out
for her Halloween party in season two
the ghost trap from Dustin's
Ghostbusters costume Hopper's police
badge the star Court malls neon sign a
box of Egos and a Chips Ahoy uniform hat
front and center of the poster is a copy
of will byer's missing poster from the
first season will the wise's wizard hat
Will's mind flayer drawing from season
two and the makeshift blackout goggles
the kids made for 11 out of a surfer boy
pizza box like I said most of those
details are pretty easy to spot for the
average stranger things fan but here's
where the poster goes deeper see all
those Tentacles from the upside down
snaking their way around certain items
if you look closely you'll notice that
these squiddly guys are only wrapped
around the items that belong to the
people who have been taken by the upside
down at the bottom of the poster the
tentacles don't curl themselves around
the ship's Ahoy hat the Eggos the ghost
trap or the surfer boy goggles but they
do entangle themselves around Will's
missing poster his drawing and his
wizard hat these Vines are also wrapped
around Eddie's guitar the clock Max's
Walkman Steve's baseball bat and the
trashcan lid all items that eventually
travel to the realm that Lies Beneath
our own but the most interesting
tentacle in my opinion is the one
bursting out of the top of the hellfire
club t-shirt this is the first clue that
tells me that Eddie might come back as a
member of beckner's Army in season five
the way that the tentacle is shooting
straight through the neck of this shirt
makes me think that we may see a
practical variation of that exact
situation on screen my theory is that
Eddie will return as a member of
vechna's army perhaps even as The
Stranger Things version of the d d
character Cass but let me explain myself
first and then I'll come back to cast in
a second I really think that bringing
Eddie back is the right-hand man of the
series big bad is The Logical conclusion
in the aftermath of season four for
starters Joseph Quinn's character was
absolutely a fan favorite seriously you
still cannot log on to twitter.com
without seeing a bunch of Eddie Munson
super fans and I'm one of them do you
know how many people will lose their
[ __ ] if he returns Netflix wants your
money baby and they know that Joseph
Quinn will bring in those sweet sweet
views second of all we also know that
becna and the mind flayer love turning
human victims into the flight using
their all-consuming powers to force
these poor folks to carry out their
destructive Deeds just look at what
happened to Billy and the other people
who got infected in season three and now
that the upside Down's dark parallel
reality is rapidly leaking into Hawkins
it'll be all too easy for him to use
Eddie to capture even more servants
thirdly we also learned this season that
11 has the power to bring a person back
to life from the brink of death when Max
is killed by vecna she manages to
reverse the damage enough to place her
in a comatose state instead the last
time we saw saw her she was actively
working to help bring Max back to
reality inside her Consciousness which
gives me the hope that she'll wake up in
season five because Ellen one's powers
are so similar I believe that becna also
has the power to resurrect Eddie in the
upside down I'm a thankful kind of
person I'm thankful for big things like
the existence of dogs and I'm thankful
for the small things like websites that
are easy to use and look cool it's not
my power to just snap my fingers and put
more pugs out there into the world but
thanks to Squarespace anybody can put up
a good looking website Squarespace is
the all-in-one platform and it makes it
easy to create update and maintain a
beautiful online presence for your
business you don't want your website
looking like something that was hard
coded into HTML back in 1998. you want
it looking and functioning like the
cream of the 2022 craft and Squarespace
can help you do that Squarespace has a
bunch of great features to help your
business be successful you can present
members only gated content create email
campaigns or add online booking for
appointments or sessions all from the
Squarespace interface my favorite aspect
is the analytics section that's where
Squarespace makes it easy to dig into
what's working and what's not and figure
out what levers you can pull to make
your business even more successful head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain now let's look at
why I think Eddie could resurrect a
stranger things as variation of cast the
bloody handed if you don't spend every
waking hour of your free time playing
Dungeons and Dragons congratulations
what's that like here's what's up with
the character Cass was dekna's most
loyal lieutenant and wielder of the sort
of cast a sentient all black longsword
although Hopper was technically the one
with an actual sword last season the
spear that Eddie takes to battle is a
close alternative also the song that
Eddie plays before his untimely death
Master of Puppets by Metallica could be
a hint that he will become vekna's
literal puppet carrying out his bidding
at the beginning of next season after
years of servitude de vecna the sword
itself actually Whispers to Cass
convincing him to betray his master
after usurping vekna's power pass is
thrown across vechna's Citadel cavities
on the plane of Ash where he develops
vampiric powers and changes his name to
cast The Destroyer I don't think to
remind you guys but Eddie Munson is
associated with bat imagery and Stranger
Things Not only does he have a flock of
bats tattooed on his forearm he's also
slain by demobats in the upside down
after fighting them off with his
makeshift sword and shield and while I
don't think that Eddie is actually going
to come back to life as a blood-sucking
vamp I do think that these symbols could
be a subtle nod to cass's DND lore more
likely in my opinion is that Eddie will
come back as a mind flare zombie hybrid
initially working for vecna before
ultimately betraying him after all he is
a huge fan of Iron Maiden and their
zombie Mass Stop Eddie would be a
perfect parallel to our favorite heavy
metal team becna could totally use his
reanimated corpse to terrorize his
former friends when becna managed to
escape the Citadel cavities in d d both
Realms were destroyed sending cass's
soul to survive outside of time and
space with the new ability to lend his
powers to binders binders are a d d
class with the ability to host the
powers that have chosen Vestige held in
life and it could make sense to have
something similar happen in stranger
things 5. we could see Eddie displaced
Hawkins and the upside down fall to 11
souped-up Powers I'm not
I'm not the only sold on the idea that
they'll suspend Eddie's soul in limbo
for eternity because that would be an
even crueler send-off than when he was
partially devoured by demopats but I do
think that light casts he will
absolutely use his pseudo zombie powers
to betray vechna which will in turn
allow 11 to hit that a-hole with her
best shot next let's talk about those
brand new Netflix avatars you'll notice
that each of them has a different
background color indicating which group
they're a part of the purple squares
showed the Hawkins gang yellow squares
feature the California crew and team
Hopper Joyce and Murray have blue
squares standing apart from the rest is
vechnus teal square but here's where it
gets interesting at first glance I
almost didn't notice that Eddie's Avatar
also had a background color because his
long beautiful locks are taking up most
of the square but in the upper right
hand corner you can see a tiny triangle
of teal peeking through the same color
as vechnas to me personally this is a
huge sign that Eddie will return on
beckner's side at least in the beginning
of the season if these colorful squares
delineate which team each character is a
part of it's clear to me that Eddie will
be team vecna to start like I've already
said like three times I believe that
he'll redeem himself by the end of the
series by betraying his puppet master
and that brings me to the final bit of
noteworthy news from stranger things day
we now know that the first episode of
season five is titled the crawl which
has a ton of possible meanings could
this be a Dungeon Crawl episode where
our Hawkins Heroes will have to navigate
their way through a Labyrinth of vekna's
design solving puzzles avoiding traps
and combating with demo beasts could the
party return to the upside down to
retrieve Eddie's body only to find him
stationed as vetna's new lieutenant or
will we literally see Eddie's corpse
crawl out of the parallel realm and into
Hawkins in a zombified form personally I
think the those scenarios are all
equally possible although I am leaning
more towards the crawl as a badass
Dungeon Crawl up but what do you guys
think will Eddie return his vechna's
servant will he rebel against Authority
like the metal head he is or will his
corpse simply rotten the upside down
until someone decides to throw him a
funeral let me know in the comments
below follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]